we're we're too often starting close to
where the Democrats are starting and
then of course when you get a compromise
or some kind of deal
I don't even call them compromises
really because generally speaking
they're just I mean it's it's BS frankly
I am Nicolas be with reason TV and today
we're very happy to be talking with
Justin Amash he's a congressman from the
third District of Michigan and he's one
of the leading libertarian Republicans
in Congress talk a little bit about what
is your general political philosophy I
mean Reason magazine we've called you
the heir apparent to the Ron Paul you
know to the romp mantle of Ron Paul you
know is that accurate and in what ways
you know what is your political
philosophy well I'm a libertarian
Republican a constitutional conservative
a classical liberal some people come got
more Austrians on your wall than the Von
Trapp Family Singers I mean Estes as I'm
a big believer in the Austrian School of
Economics but you know I'm an
independent and a moderate many people
would look at my voting record and say
this is a moderate guy yeah he's willing
to work with both sides he's willing to
do what the founders intended this for
this country and and not just play the
political games that has led to some
friction within the Republican caucus in
coming back to Congress in this term you
were stripped of a couple of committee
assignments a member of the Republican
steering committee of when asked why
were you and a couple of other free
market oriented libertarian oriented
congressmen taken off of certain
committees said well these guys were
[ __ ] is that an accurate assessment
of why you were taking off these
committees no I don't think so I mean if
you asked my colleagues I don't think
anyone would use that word to describe
me except a few people on the steering
committee I guess but look I I said I
didn't support the House budget last
time I had good reasons for it it didn't
explain it a little bit what was wrong
with the House budget this is a budget
that has widely praised as being
fiscally responsible and it engages
entitlement reform what was wrong with
the Republic well let me say first that
it's a it's a huge advancement over
budgets we've seen in recent years I
mean we haven't seen anything from the
Democrats in a long time so I do applaud
Paul Ryan and the Budget Committee for
putting together something that's way
better than what we've seen before but
it didn't comply with the Budget Control
Act which was passed into law so it was
going to
nor the Budget Control Act it tried to
undo essentially many of the military
spending reductions that were put in
place under the Budget Control Act I
didn't like that and it was still gonna
take about 30 years to balance and I
think we can do better than that
yeah I mean the Republican budget takes
over a 10-year period it moves spending
from about three three and a half
trillion dollars to about four point
nine trillion why is that the best that
the Republicans you know who run the
House of Representatives why is that the
best that they can come up with it
doesn't come close to balancing the
budget it doesn't reduce spending
clearly we're we're too often starting
close to where the Democrats are
starting and then of course when you get
a compromise or some kind of deal
I don't even call them compromises
really because generally speaking
they're just I mean it's it's BS frankly
when you talk about where your starting
point is it should be very different
from what the Democrats are pushing
because the Republican parties should
stand for very different things you have
a budget balanced legislation or a piece
of budget balance like a balanced budget
legislation in the works explain what
that is and how it's different not only
from what the Democrats are proposing
with from some what other Republicans
have proposed well what it does is it
balances current spending with the
average revenues of the previous three
years and that has a lot of nice effects
that the people in both parties like if
you are looking at it from from the case
where you don't want government spending
to be suddenly cut during the recession
well this balanced budget amendment
allows you to to keep spending at the
level of the previous three years of
revenue so if you have a sudden
recession your tax revenues are low you
don't have to suddenly slash government
programs you can do it in a more
calculated way you can think about the
long run and if you are worried about
tax increases well I think it's got a
good defense against tax increases
because you have to make the case that
you want to increase taxes for the long
run under my proposal because any tax
increases that you that are incurred in
the current year can't be used for
current year spending over the past
three years or so and I'm probably off a
bit but we've pulled in about probably
an average of about two trillion dollars
a year which would be equal to what we
Bente in bill clinton's last budget year
roughly but we're spending about three
and a half trillion dollars so we you
know we're somewhere in the trillion two
trillion and a half dollar deficit range
how does your bill propose to you know
deal with that massive gap well it deals
with it by forcing the parties to get
together and actually compromise
i mean when you have compromise that's
got to be toward some goal the goal is
deficit reduction and debt reduction the
biggest areas of government are social
security defense
medicare and medicaid you got to put all
those things on the table and come up
with a deal the baseline defense budget
is about five hundred billion dollars a
year assuming that the sequester goes
through what should it be if that's you
know it's one of the biggest items in
the budget how much should that be cut
well I don't know what the specific
number should be but I think when you
look at all of our operations around the
globe if you look at the fact that we're
still subsidizing Western Europe and
Korea and many of the Arab countries
you've got a problem here these these
other countries don't even need to have
a defense they're relying on the United
States and we're spending about forty
five percent of the world's budget on
defense if we drop down to forty two
percent of the world's budget would
would be in would we be in danger I
don't think so
contrary to Leon Panetta the outgoing
Secretary of Defense who said that you
know the sequester means that we may not
be able to defend ourselves you think
that well totally well well for people
who say that did they think that we
couldn't defend ourselves under george w
bush in 2008 we're dropping back to
george george w bush levels of military
spending toward the end of his term so
not even at the beginning at the
beginning of this term we were somewhere
around probably three hundred billion so
we're much higher than that and for
those who say it's devastating they also
have to say that george w bush's defense
level was devastating talk a little bit
about foreign policy because i mean you
are a you're not what would is either
called disparagingly an isolationist or
in a in more polite company in non - non
interventionist how do you how do you
define your foreign policy and what's a
libertarian vision of foreign policy
that is not simply saying you know the
world should just go away
well it's a constitutional foreign
policy and your your right to say it's
not isolationist because isolationist is
actually what's promoted often by other
people within the Republican Party
within within the Democratic Party its
isolationist when you decide that how
you deal with countries that are threats
you just put sanctions on them and more
sanctions and isolate them that's
isolationism I've called for
non-interventionism which is we don't
send our troops everywhere in the world
to deal with everyone else's problems we
have to defend the homeland here and we
follow a constitutional policy
so everything that if there's a threat
then the president comes to Congress and
says here's a threat and Congress has to
pass a authorization for for war and
then then the president is authorized to
do what do what he needs to do but it
should always go back to the people's
house
the American forces that were used in
Libya that's clearly on Constitution
yeah clearly unconstitutional should be
invaded Afghanistan I think so yeah at
the time and it should be it should have
been for a limited purpose to take out
the terrorists who targeted us on 9/11
so we should we have been out by 2002
2003 something like well I don't know
what year specifically but I think that
you know once the trail gets cold and
you're not accomplishing any objectives
then you shouldn't have your troops
there I mean if the the way to go after
al-qaeda was to have a massive army on
the ground then you think we would have
gotten their leaders a long time ago but
it took us a while and and we didn't
even get some of them in Afghanistan it
was in other parts of the world so we
need to think about how we do it in a
smart way I think we were always
authorized to go after the leaders of
al-qaeda I don't think there's any doubt
about that I don't think there was any
doubt we had the authority to go after
bin Laden wherever he was but you can't
use this ongoing authorization to say
well you can now go to war anywhere in
the world against any single person who
might seem like a threat but going after
somebody like bin Laden in Pakistan say
is that you know does is that legal do
you think under the authorization that
sanctioned
intervening in Afghanistan I think so to
go after bin Laden because he was a
clear he was clearly in charge of the
operation I think it was it was legal to
go after him I think there are a lot of
other situations where it's more
questionable and if we're going after
people who have nothing to do with 9/11
it's it's clear that they they were not
the people organizing 9/11 whether
they're terrorists or not what they have
or it's the president's job to come back
to Congress and say this is who we're
going after and this is why and for
Congress to give the authorization
should we have gone into Iraq I don't
think so in retrospect I mean I think it
was more questionable at the time but I
think in retrospect no I mean I wasn't
in Congress I was pretty young at the
time so I don't I don't remember it as
well as talking earlier you had said
that you were 21 when 9/11 happened in
2001 was that a formative experience for
you and in a meaningful way in terms of
how you think about politics or
America's role in the world well it had
it had a big impact on me I mean I think
I cried for six days I mean it was it
was not a small deal to me when that
happened yeah like like for every
American I mean every American felt that
way and it got me more interested in
politics you know I don't think I
developed some of my more libertarian
leanings you know in a clear way where I
understood what I would I really
believed until I was probably well out
of college well out of law school even
but you know I it did have a big impact
on my life and and I felt like you know
this this country is is important it's
it's the beacon of Liberty for the world
do you think that the 9/11 attacks and
this you know some people said it at the
time well this was blowback or this was
a kind of obvious reaction to the way
America had conducted foreign policy
particularly in the Middle East but
elsewhere for decades is that a
legitimate reading of 9/11 or is that
just off-base well I think you can't you
know blame everything on blowback and
you also
to have the United States say well we're
not you know our actions overseas don't
have any impact on other people I mean
you got to look at look at the totality
of it and certainly there are things
that we do overseas that incite people
and get people upset that doesn't give
them any justification to come here and
commit terrorist attacks against
innocent people but certainly we need to
look at our foreign policy and make sure
that we are not
riling people up what should we be doing
with Syria I mean this seems - you know
here's a case where we have a dictator
who's a horrible horrible leader who
commits atrocities on a daily basis but
[ __ ] does you know what does that mean
to the United States at this point yeah
my mom Syrian so I understand the
situation a little bit I think that of
course Assad is a dictator what what his
regime is doing is horrible they're
committing crimes against the people on
a daily basis and and war crimes against
his people but the the fact is our
national defense should be used for you
know our defense here in the United
States and I think it's it's very
dangerous if we get in the habit of
deciding who the good guys are and who
the bad guys are because as bad as Assad
is you don't know who's gonna come and
replace them they may be just as bad and
suddenly you've helped armed people who
are then gonna commit the same kind of
atrocities and maybe come use it against
the United States so you have to be very
careful when you get involved in this
stuff and I think if there's a clear
threat to the United States of course
then the president should come to
Congress and get the authorization
necessary so how does that play out in
relation to Iran which is certainly more
of a threat should the u.s. be isolating
Iran through trade sanctions should they
be engaging them through open trade how
you know what's the best way to kind of
work towards some kind of positive
resolution but for people in Iran as
well as for the United States I think
that sanctions that are directed toward
preventing them from getting weapons of
mass destruction I think those sections
are are useful and helpful especially in
the short run I'm not sure you'd want to
use them for 20 years eventually you
have to say well they're not working if
they eventually develop a weapon you say
well what's the point of
sanctions but there are other sanctions
that are more targeted at the people of
Iran I think those are not beneficial to
the United States so you have to you
have to weigh what kind of sanctions but
yeah it's a situation you need to watch
closely and if I felt Iran was a genuine
threat to the United States I'd give the
president authorization to do what's
necessary DUI I assume that you think
that Americans should be able to trade
freely with Cuba yeah yeah so should we
be able to trade freely with Iran in the
same way I mean subject to certain kinds
of you know okay not military technology
or something I think so but again it
depends on what you're trading with them
I think there there should be efforts to
prevent any sorts of weapons or
especially weapons of mass destruction
from entering Iran so you have to watch
it and monitor it very carefully but you
know trading handbags and those kind of
things I don't I don't think that's
gonna wow is what you've just defined as
a kind of libertarian policy of both
engagement and you know when using the
military when necessary how is that at
all objectionable to so many people in
the Republican caucus I mean you hear
people you know think tanks in DC
Republican think tanks saying we need to
have a certain amount of the budget
always going to defense no matter what
we can never cut spending etc I mean is
it is your message getting through to
your colleagues I think it actually is
if you look at some of the newer members
in Congress I mean look at Thomas Massie
but but many of the new members they
have a different perspective on this and
and I'd say we're you know I wouldn't
say that they all have a libertarian
perspective on foreign policy but it's
you know you have a couple dozen maybe
three dozen people who lean more in that
direction I don't think you had that ten
years ago and the message of just spend
spend spend on on military spending is
it doesn't make sense we have a huge
national debt and the biggest threat to
our countries to let that national debt
grow and eventually when we have a
situation when we actually need military
spending we actually need the money to
go into our military to fight a major
war we won't have that money so why
would we burn
the money now when we don't have a major
threat to the United States instead of
saving the money so that when we do have
a major threat we actually have it then
we might have a defense budget that's
even much bigger than it is now but it
would be justified because there's an
actual threat to the United States
speaking of you know what's growing the
national debt Medicare spending is
certainly you know it's one of the
largest items in the budget now and it's
only gonna get bigger and bigger and
everybody agrees that Medicare spending
more than anything else is the time bomb
in in federal spending what should be
done about Medicare well you need some
reform to make it more like a private
system I mean you need when when you
look at it though the biggest problem is
the rising cost of health care it's it's
not even so much that it's a government
operated system it's that healthcare
costs are rising and the reason health
care costs are rising is because there's
a huge disconnect between what people
are receive and what people pay because
they don't know what they're paying for
they go to the doctor and they ask for
medication or they ask for a procedure
they don't know how much it costs the
doctor doesn't know how much it cost
I've talked to many doctors to tell me
patients come in they don't even know
what to tell them when they when they're
asked about how much something costs
that's it that's a big problem for
Obamacare I mean health care reform did
nothing to address that base that's Eska
debt that's not addressed at all so
you've got Medicare that will rise in
cost over the years because of that
you've got Obamacare that will have
rising costs because it doesn't address
that issue it's it's a with Medicare
though I mean Paul Ryan was you know
really demagogue for supposedly you know
destroying the idea of Medicare as an
open-ended entitlement and replacing it
with vouchers that would allow people
advised a policy is that actually a good
idea and it's just that he set the level
of the voucher to high I mean how do we
restrain or how do we bring that
information loop of what what mental
health care costs to people so they
understand it and reduce health care
it's a better system that we have now I
don't think it ultimately addresses all
of the problem problems with rising
health care costs as I said but the the
Paul Ryan suggested system were what
work much better than what we have now
and it actually makes the healthcare
system operate a lot like congressional
health care operates I mean it's it's
not truly a voucher system you you pick
something from you pick your health care
from congressionally government approved
plans and then the government chips in a
portion of it and you chip in a portion
of it you mentioned that your mother is
from Syria your father is from Palestine
he moved to Michigan in the late 50s in
56 and talked a little bit about how the
experience of having parents who are
immigrants to America how does that
inform your position on immigration
which has become a really you know is
also a front-burner issue now well the
immigration is and is an important thing
for this country I mean everyone at some
point for the most part was an immigrant
who came they came here from somewhere
else and it's important to have a
regular flow of immigrants I think the
the biggest problem we have is having a
welfare state and this is the problem
Europe has it's it's not so much that
they have a large immigrant flow into
the countries it's that when you have a
large welfare state there's not as much
assimilation into the culture so what's
happened historically in the United
States because we haven't had a strong
welfare states as Europe people come
here and they assimilate they adapt they
go to work they become a part of the
culture and they become Americans and
and that's what you'd like to see going
forward and do you think that has slowed
down in recent years or is it more that
people are fear-mongering the idea that
that is not well there's only it's a
little bit of both I mean I think the
the welfare state has grown in the
United States I mean it's not just at
the federal level but at the state level
and that's a big part of it there's also
a lot of fear out there and and a lot of
that has to do with our poor economy for
many years I mean the worst of the
economy is the more people want to blame
someone and they'll blame immigrants do
you think we should create a pathway to
citizenship quickly for illegal
immigrants who are already here well I
think giving them some kind of legal
status or legal resident status would be
a good idea but there has to be a system
in place first there's no system really
in a place for immigrants to come here
as
country we don't have a good immigration
system a league we don't have a good
legal immigration system so you got to
put that in place and then if someone
came here illegally then they should get
in the back of the line and come in the
appropriate way but we're not gonna have
a sis but does that mean that you're
should they self-deport and then get
online you know on the other side of the
Mexican border which is I guess what
we're we inevitably are talking about
with immigration or well I don't know if
they self deport I would say that we're
not gonna have a system where we take
you know cops door-to-door and round up
every illegal immigrant and deport them
I don't think that's feasible or
plausible if someone is here and they
commit a crime and they happen to be an
illegal immigrant of course they could
be deported
nobody is nobody's arguing against that
but we need a system in place that
allows these those who have come here
illegally to to become legal or is the
border secure enough or do we have to
you know build a bigger wall or a
tighter wall or a triple wall before we
can start processing people who are here
illegally well it's it's clearly not
secure enough but that doesn't mean you
have to build bigger walls or have
tighter security I think the the biggest
reason we have an influx is we don't
have a system for people to come here
legally there are people who want to
come here and they want to work for a
few months and go back to their home
countries and I think we should we
should make that available to people and
if you don't have a good legal
immigration system you're going to
encourage illegal immigration and that's
what we have and that's why you have so
many illegal immigrants the number of
illegal immigrants would drop
dramatically if you had a good legal
immigration system you have speaking of
immigrants or people from foreign
countries behind you you've got a wall
full of Austrian economists as well as
at least one Frenchman Frederic Bastiat
you have Ludwig von Mises up there
Friedrich Hayek karl menger and murray
rothbard who was a stranger in his own
country let's talk a little bit about
your intellectual underpinnings I mean
you went to University of Michigan as an
undergrad you went to law school there
so obviously you did not get a good
education but after I mean where do you
where did your interest in Austrian
economists or in Frederic Bastiat the
French
journalist and thinker where did where
did that come from and where is it
leading well it developed after law
school actually I was I found that my
views although I was Republican were
different than a number of conservatives
in my class there weren't that many
there's probably five at my law school
but everybody was different than those
five and you've said that you know one
of the things you notice that when it
came to when you would talk to
conservatives in a legal setting they
would always be on the side of the
prosecutor you would be on the side of
the defendant yeah yeah I had a natural
sympathy toward the defense side of
things I believe strongly in protecting
people's constitutional rights and and
making sure they get due process and you
know I spent some time thinking about
what it is my views were and I actually
did a Google search I went on Google and
I searched terms that were you know
basically my views and do you remember
what they were safe search on or off I
don't remember but FA Hyack popped up
pretty quick I mean who is either the
top pick or or somewhere along there had
you ever encountered Hayek as an
undergrad or in law school I don't
believe so and I studied economics as an
undergrad and I don't remember Hayek
ever being talked about you know you
hear about Friedman from time to time
what was it a bad Hayek's work and then
you know other people like Sean paid or
Mises or whatever I mean what is it
about it that you find particularly
interesting and relevant and and and
meaningful to to your life as a
legislator well with Hayek I mean it was
the connection was pretty pretty clear
instantly I mean he believed really
strongly in this spontaneous order that
that things would come together on their
own it was sort of like an evolutionary
process and if you allow people to make
decisions they've got the knowledge
because they're close you know decisions
they're making our closest to them why
should someone else make it from far
away and if you allow people to make
their own decisions you actually get
good outcomes for society
and that that really is something that I
think about a lot as a legislator now
behind me I believe on the wall there's
also a picture of ein rant talk about
brand when did you encounter her and and
how does she speak to your to your
worldview well I mean randa's uh speaks
in a sort of different way I mean it's
it's more of an emotional appeal and I
don't remember when I and I where she
would be very angry to hear that I don't
I know I know I know but when I you know
when I read some of her works I I find
myself connecting to a lot of the
characters I I sort of feel the same
frustrations they feel and and I think
that's that's an important aspect of her
work when did you first encounter rant
Oh probably not till four or five years
ago mm-hmm and so I mean when you read a
novel Atlas Shrugged or The Fountainhead
you find you the frustration of being
hemmed in by kind of overreaching
legislators and business interests yeah
sure and and and rants philosophy is
very different from Hayek's I mean there
they come to many of the same
conclusions about what kind of you know
government you should have and what kind
of social order you ultimately would get
but but they think about it in very
different ways and I find that
interesting and Bastiat another person
who appeals emotionally and and is very
different from Hayek but but adds
something to the to the conversation
what you--what do you what's the kind of
spice that this Frenchman adds well I
mean it's a it's a nice French spice I
mean it's it's uh it's short stories
almost parables about about folly the
folly of government and and
interventionism and the folly of
restricting free trade and I think
that's it's it's beautiful to read I
mean when you read boss yachts work
people are really compelled to to agree
with it I mean it's it's it's hard to
refute and I actually give away the law
when people stop by my office I
copies of the law I give to people is it
a hard sell in contemporary Michigan or
in the industrial Midwest to say look
guys your economy has been tanking here
for a long time the answer is free trade
as opposed to the answer is more
protectionism well it's it's always
going to be a hard sell with some people
there's no doubt about that if you're in
a particular industry that's that's
getting benefits from protectionism then
yeah it's gonna be a hard sell to you
but protectionism doesn't help people it
helps the people in those companies and
those people in those companies are a
small percentage of the population so
I'm concerned about the entire
population in my district the entire
population of the state of Michigan and
the United States everyone is a consumer
only some people work in particular
industries so it doesn't make sense to
have laws in place to protect particular
industries and then hurt 100% of the
people you also have a picture of Murray
Rothbard
talk a little bit you know Murray
Rothbard is a big anarchy
anarcho-capitalist bomb thrower what do
you what do you find particularly
compelling about his work
well I think he's he gives an
interesting anarchist perspective and
I'm not there I'm a libertarian I I fall
more in the Hayek camp and I think it's
important to understand his work to
understand his way of thinking because
when you have discussions with those who
are on the anarcho-capitalist side of
things it's important to understand
where he's coming from where they're
coming from so you can make your
arguments to persuade I mean I
ultimately think there's there's got to
be some government there will be some
government I believe in a sort of a
minimal government state and you're
gonna have different levels of different
amounts of government at different
levels at the federal level it should be
very small in how it affects your daily
life and it should just deal with things
of national scope and at closer levels
local government or your Neighborhood
Association well it might have a huge
impact on your daily life but it's
certainly not going to protect you from
an invasion
you know how possible is it to actually
you know resize the air you know to
shrink the size scope and spending of
government well you've got to convince
people that things can be done at the
local level or the state level there are
a lot of people out there who are afraid
of
government leaving they don't want to
see no government they think when they
hear a libertarian or a conservative
saying we want smaller government
there's going to be no government that's
not really what most of us are arguing
we're just arguing there should be
different sizes of government in
different places and if you want a large
local government then that's fine it's
up to you and your it's up to your local
community but the thing that's nice
about it the thing that's nice about our
system of federalism is if you've got
too big of government at the local level
and you don't like it you can move to
the town next door but if the United
States has too big of government and
it's affecting all 100% of the people in
the United States it's very difficult to
leave what are you gonna go to another
country I mean that's basically your
only option and there's no country
that's actually a freer than the United
States at least historically we may be
losing that that title
you're a outspoken advocate for second
Amendment rights talk about your worries
at the at the federal level you know of
about those rights being taken away well
the the founders were very clear that
they didn't want the government
intruding on those rights and you have
to think about the Second Amendment in
the context in which it was drafted they
had just fought an armed revolution
against their own government and a lot
of people forget that that's the that's
where the second amendment came from and
they understood that it was important to
protect that right so that no government
no future government could ever take
away the people's right to defend
themselves and that's what the founders
intended and this idea that well if you
had a corrupt government that tried to
attack the people of the United States
they couldn't stand up for themselves
with with small arms I disagree with
that I think people can protect
themselves and I'm not suggesting that
our current government or any government
in the future is going to use any force
against the you know against United
States citizens or people who live here
but the founders believed that it was an
important protection to have in place
because they did face that situation
they actually did face the situation
where their own government came against
them one of the things that seems to
drive people crazy about libertarians as
libertarians prized consistency or
systemic thinking
and so that you know the idea is that
conservatives might say well government
should be small except for defense
spending and that it can you know kind
of really run up the credit card or
social issues we should have a small
government but then when it comes to
certain types of bedroom issues whether
it's things like abortion or
reproductive rights or gay marriage
where do you come down on those issues
what what your should there be a federal
recognition of same-sex marriages well I
don't think there should be a federal
definition of marriage so I think the
federal government should just stay out
of this really marriage should be a
private contract that has nothing to do
with government how does that play into
things like the tax code because it's
clear that you know should we get rid of
any kind of married status and filing of
taxes then ultimately yeah I think so I
mean we're not even close to that
situation now and it may be the case
that were marriage is so tied into the
tax code and other benefits that what
will ultimately happen is that gay
people will be allowed to marry under
you know some kind of federalized
version of marriage what about abortion
I'm pro-life 100% pro-life I think it's
so okay what does what does that mean
though in terms of should the federal
government ban all abortions or is
should that be left to localities or the
states or how do you work that through a
kind of understanding you know as you
were talking about of different levels
of government that are you know looking
at different parts of life well I think
you know when you have the case of
abortion you've got two people involved
you've got you've got a baby and you've
got a parent and I think it falls within
the Equal Protection Clause of the
Fourteenth Amendment
so in current under current federal law
or constitutional readings the state
does not have an interest in you know
fetus or in a pregnancy for the first
trimester you would say that that's an
error how far you know how far back to
the moment of conception should it go I
think that's it's a tricky question
but I think that where we haven't now is
not correct it should be closer to the
point of conception and whether it's
instantly or the first three days I
think that's more sensible and that's
what
that's what I think what we would be
correct I argue against birth control
are you in favor of certain types of
birth control but not others or could
you speak to that sir I haven't thought
about all the types of birth control but
I'm certainly there are certain types of
birth control that I would consider you
know abortion cause II and there are
other birth kinetics of birth control
that I think will be fine so do you or
do you think that we're getting I mean
we're still in the kind of early stages
of really controlling our reproduction
in in a lot of ways I mean the birth
oral pill only came out in about 1960
was only made legal to non-married women
unmarried women in the early 70s will as
our technology of kind of controlling
our bodies gets better will abortion be
less of an issue or do you think it'll
always be there well I think abortion
will be an issue in the near future but
you you might eventually get to the
point where a baby is viable at a very
early stage and and more people going
and fall into the pro-life position
you're an Orthodox Christian talk a bit
about how that informed your kind of
upbringing and how it informs your
legislative profile if it does and and
if it doesn't why doesn't it well I
there's a strong emphasis in our church
on free will and the the mystery of the
order of the world and I think that
really fits in well with with my views
I'm not sure that you know growing up
that that my views were nicely shaped by
that my political views but they
definitely do mesh together very well I
believe strongly in the idea of free
will people can make up their own mind
about how they live their lives and and
they will be judged accordingly either
positively or negatively you know what
are what are the most important issues
that America has to grapple with in in
this next two-year period in this next
congressional term it's got to be debt
and I think civil liberties as well but
debt is number one I mean you you have
to get the debt under control because
eventually it there's that clock any
time you you know somebody says
something about reducing debt in
Congress that bells go off
it's the president yes he's trying to
stop me so you know we got to get our
debt under control does that mean not
raising the debt limit at the end of
march or or brokering a tough deal to
say okay you know we will have a
short-term increase but it's got to
start coming down I don't think you
raised the debt limit unless you get
major reforms to major programs and and
in the here-and-now not yet a years down
yeah you got to get you've got to get
the laws changed now and some of those
mandatory programs yeah it does take a
while for the the cost savings to kick
in because of the way they work but
you've got to make the changes
immediately talk a little bit about how
your votes against things like the
national defense reauthorization act and
whatnot played out in your party and how
how you will continue to push for
broader civil liberties going forward we
haven't had good protection for civil
liberties in either the Republican Party
or the Democratic Party for many years I
mean you have a few members but not not
that many who are that outspoken about
it and I think the Republican Party is
actually coming along more in the
direction of my way of thinking and yeah
many young Republicans that protecting
civil liberties is one of the most
important things our country our
government should do I mean it's really
the reason for the founding was to
protect civil liberties of Americans so
when you look at various issues like
drones I'm not against drones as as an
object I don't object to the idea that
there that there be drones
I think drones can be a useful weapon in
war but any use of drones should be
authorized by Congress and it shouldn't
be just you know open-ended use of force
against anyone that the President sees
as a threat without any approval from
Congress the same with the National
Defense Authorization Act there may be
reasons to detain people but it should
be in the context of war and it can't be
so broad that you can actually come into
the into a home in the United States and
grab an American citizen out of his home
and detain him not tell his family
anything and say well we think he might
be associated with terrorists that's
that's the current law and that's
frightening that's not what our founders
intended a final question you're the
parent of three children yes
what are you what would you say the odds
are from you know zero to a hundred
percent of you know that they will that
they will come of age in a richer and
free or America or one that has just
either gone sideways or actually gone
downhill in terms of producing wealth
and freedom well I have to say the odds
are pretty high I think that there it's
still 90 percent odds because I I really
do believe in the American people and my
you know my dad and mom came here as
immigrants they came here with nothing
there is a spirit here that is
independent that's libertarian in many
ways and and it's in pretty much
everyone I run into regardless of their
political affiliation so I think that
it's still strong and when I go to town
halls I get a good reception so I think
we still can turn this thing around but
not with the current Congress or the
current president and it's gonna take
some some changes and some time well
with that we'll leave it there thank you
so much representative Justin Amash of
the third District of Michigan thanks
for talking to Reason TV thanks